[Applaudissements]
quel temps pourri tout est peint quelle
vie de merde il y en a ras-le-bol
pas vous mon chauffeur de taxi semble
s'être levé du mauvais pied
elle moins qu'on puisse dire
instantanément mon plexus se bloque mon
tout s'accélère pour autant je ne laisse
pas piéger par une réaction épidermique
qui ne manquerait pas d'alimenter son
humeur grise bon dirais je n'ai pas
beaucoup de mérite
hier encore je m'extasiais à la vue
d'une valve est majestueuse piqueté de
girafe à la robe étoilée les hautes
herbes rouges et jaunes ondulé dans le
vent avec grâce ouais pour tout vous
dire je reviens du kenya de chez les
massaï
vous savez ces fameux guerrier assoiffés
de sang et de trophées
c'est bête de proies magnifique mais
dangereuse non je plaisante
là c'est le mythe dans lequel on les
enferme on enferme ses pasteurs nomades
emblématique d'afrique de l'est depuis
un siècle et demi non moi si j'y
retourne depuis si longtemps c'est parce
qu'à l' inverse de ce cliché grotesque
je suis porteur d'un virus très doux
très humain qu'ils m'ont transmis
lorsque j'étais enfant et caïn anglais
passionné maladie d'amour qu'un anglais
passionné a baptisé masse haïti dans les
années 1940
pour la petite histoire les
administrateurs anglais
de la réserve massaï au temps de la
colonie voyez régulièrement leur
autorité sapé par ce mal étrange au
point que la reine d'angleterre
elle-même dû prendre un décret royal
leur interdisant de rester en poste plus
de trois mois de la même façon cette
maladie d'amour pour les masaï a zappé
chez moi toute velléité de rester sur
les rails d'un statut social tout tracé
préférant demeurer libre sensible et en
accord avec moi-même
laissez moi vous donner quelques temps
forts de mon itinéraire
ça va être très rapide à l'âge de 6 ans
je me noie puis je reviens à la vie je
fais alors un rêve étrange jusqu'à
l'adolescence où je prends mon envol
avec un homme noire drapée de rouge plus
tard guidé par tant de signes je décide
de faire de longues études
anthropologiques avec pour unique
objectif d'aller partager leur vie ce
que je fais durant trois années
trois années au coeur de la savane parmi
leurs immenses troupeaux de vaches faune
sauvage en abondance alors inutile de
vous dire que leur joie de vivre très
contagieuse très contagieuse n'a fait
que accroître mon état d'addiction au
masai celui ci deviendra deviendra
d'ailleurs très vite irréversible au
point que une décennie plus tard je
déciderai de démissionner de toutes mes
fonctions universitaires et dieu sait si
elles étaient nombreuses pour
transmettre en toute liberté comme je le
fais ce soir devant vous et pour la
première fois un certain monde parle des
massaï les vertus de ce merveilleux
virus
on l'aurait presque oublié mais je suis
toujours dans mon taxi
l'ambiance y est lourde je préfère
repenser à la magnifique bénédiction que
mme assuré hier un vénérable sage à la
première lueur de l'aurore salutations
obsessed laisse la sensibilité de notre
ami s'épanouir à l'image de ton
ascension lente et sur la sla grandir
sans bruit car dans mon taxi je me dis
si au lieu de m'énerver je prenais sur
moi de rester calme de garder mon calme
et si je considérais mon chauffeur avec
amour avec empathie si finalement ce que
l'on dégagé avait un impact déterminant
sur le comportement des autres je me
concentre sur la route qui défile
puis je ferme les yeux pour mieux me
remémorer tous les bons moments que je
viens de passer au kenya
le résultat ne se fait pas attendre une
vague de paix monsieur mais rj soudain
quant à mon chauffeur petit miracle
coïncidence c'est pas son ton a
subitement changé
il sait il semble s'être apaisée d'un
seul coup comment ne pas faire le lien
avec une histoire incroyable qui m'est
arrivé il ya quelques années sur les
escaliers de montmartre alors que vous
en parler j'ai les images qui défilent
comme si je les revivait avec vous ce
soir une douzaine d'hommes aux épaules
de dockers j'ai pas si vous avez déjà vu
les hommes aux épaules de dockers c'est
moi mais ne riez pas ne riez pas en tout
cas ils étaient 12 et se rue sur moi en
me menaçant leur couteau à cran d'arrêt
mais je vais pas le faire vendre
c'était moi la syrie se ruent sur moi me
dépouille presque entièrement de pied en
cap
je suis mort de trouille mais
l'adrénaline a beau me noyer je n'ai de
cesse de m'adresser à eux avec douceur
amour empathie tendresse je m'entends
même leur expliquer que ce n'est pas de
leur faute que dans nos pays dits
développés être quelqu'un sait porter un
masque
être un homme sait faire simple semblant
d'être fort c'est ne pas pleurer
le tout petit déjà on nous apprend à
vivre séparé coupé de la source plein de
tendresse qui nous unit tous pour
avancer mais verrons pourquoi et dans
quel but
contre toute attente ils baissent leur
garde
j'en profite d'ailleurs pour leur
demander dit vous pourriez pas me rendre
ma mentale m'a été donné par ma grand
mère le jour de ma communion solennelle
et j'y tiens comme à la prunelle de mes
yeux
imaginez un peu tous ces fiers à bras
ses armoires à glace comme moi fondre
d'un seul coup devenir tout penaud et
venir la tête basse ne rendre à la queue
leu leu me rendre tout ce qu'ils m'ont
dérobée qui m'a menti mon blouson qui
met les chaussures en se confondant en
excuses et en finissant par me réclamer
comme on réclame une faveur monsieur
vous voyez pas ne riez pas dix bals s'il
vous plaît
chez les massaï j'ai appris qu'il est
normal et efficace de considérer l'autre
comme le prolongement de soi même nous
voilà donc dans mon taxi nos jours sur
le périphérique
il pleut à verse
mon chauffeur me crie vous arrivez d'où
déjà du kenya le silence s'installe que
je ne cherche pas à meubler puis à ma
grande surprise il enchaîne par deux
trois phrases déclamé avec de la joie
presque de la ferveur le kenya dit vous
en avez de la chance vous avez raison de
partir là bas c'est un pays merveilleux
c'est un vrai jardin d'éden d'ailleurs
je crois bien avoir visionné tous les
documentaires animaliers sur ce beau
pays et en plus y'a du soleil toute
l'année je suis soudain remplit
d'allégresse d' enthousiasme
c'est comme si j'avais bu un peu un peu
trop de champagne mon être pétillent
chez les massaï cette exaltation et le
produit d'une inspiration divine c'est
leur dieu féminin intérieur qui leur
permet d'avoir comme ils disent avec
infiniment de respect le regard clair et
la démarche alerte produit non pas d'une
arrogance mais d'une construction intime
d'homme libre qui est tout simplement
heureux de partager sa liberté avec les
autres pour cela nul besoin de longs
discours
cette au kosovo après les frappes de
l'otan que j'ai sans doute eu le
privilège et la de l'expérimenté avec le
plus de force et le plus de succès j'ai
organisé des réunions de réconciliation
à jour je me met d'accord avec mon
binôme pour qu'ils animent la séance
tandis que moi je m'exprime au travers
de mon silence car j'ai devant moi des
leaders serbes assez menaçant une font
d'ailleurs davantage penser à de
sinistres guerrier cas des colombes de
la paix m enfin je n'en mène pas large
je commence par conséquent à exécuter en
enfant intérieur un rituel massaï de
purification que je connais bien qui
s'appelle un copie tôt pour que je
retrouve ma joie intérieure de telle
sorte à ce que la négative
leur négativité n'est plus de prise sur
moi et que même finissent par
disparaître chez eux
rituel qui consiste à nouer
symboliquement son coeur afin d'y
enfermer le bien et le mal pour les
massaï lorsque vous mettez ensemble le
bien et le mal au plus profond de votre
coeur alors tout ce qui n'est pas
conforme ce qui n'est pas correct se
dissout de lui-même s'autodétruit
ayant toutes la réunion mon être vivre
autour d'une seule pensée prenez-vous
dans les bras les uns les autres et
faites parler votre véritable nature qui
est d'aimer sans restriction
au bout de deux heures d'un grande joie
ma grande stupéfaction la plupart des
leaders serbes se lèvent et viennent
demander pardon à l'autre quand j'en
pleure à chaudes larmes
pour moi c'est parce que ils ont accepté
de vivre l'instant au lieu de le juger
renonçant ainsi aux barrières que
l'histoire avait dressé dans leur tête
pour obéir enfin à leur sensibilité en
pays massaï faire silence est une
pratique courante
d'ailleurs leur porte parole les plus
respectés sont ceux là mêmes qui ne
parlent pas j'ai maintes fois eu
l'occasion de le constater bien sûr leur
simple présence débordante d'amour de
sensibilité suffit généralement à
réconcilier les pires ennemis et a
réveillé les coeurs les plus
récalcitrants pour les massaï
nous pouvons vivre en harmonie avec nous
même et avec les autres que la condition
que si nous laissons notre sensibilité
source de créativité et de construction
guider notre ego c'est elle notre
sensibilité qui permet de libérer tout
l'amour qui est en nous et pour cela
quoi de mieux que le silence
oui quoi de mieux que le silence mon
chauffeur taxi interrompt la méditation
il me lance comme une évidence à le
kenya le kenya
on m'avait tant fait rêver avec ce pays
on m'avait tant appris de choses sur ce
pays vous même
vraiment je n'ai plus qu'une idée en
tête c'est aussi partir à montaut mais
pourtant je réfléchis je lui ai
pratiquement pas adressé la parole
depuis l'aéroport roissy charles de
gaulle alors décidément que ce soit les
pickpockets de montmartre les leaders
serbes et maintenant mon chauffeur de
taxi me paraît évident que c'est la
solution intérieure qui est la plus
efficace pour changer positivement le
cours des choses
imaginons ce qu'aurait été le kenya si
la reine d'angleterre n'a vait pas
édicter son décret royal interdisant aux
administrateurs coloniaux de la réserve
massaï de rester en poste plus de trois
mois de peur qu'ils ne tombent amoureux
de ce peuple qu'ils ne contractent la
célèbre masse à haïti c'est qu'ils
fassent silence tout comme ses pasteurs
nomades qu'ils étaient censés gouverner
imaginons comment pourrait fonctionner
le monde notre planète si nous
abandonnions laissions tomber notre
vouloir tout contrôler si nous donnions
libre cours à notre sensibilité
enfin je les vérifier auprès des
physiciens de physique quantique
pour eux il n'y a aucun doute il existe
bel et bien une reliance universelle
entre tous les êtres vivants qui permet
à chaque
qui nous permet d'agir sur le monde par
notre transformation personnelle
alors ce soir j'ai envie de vous faire
le cadeau cette extraordinaire leçon de
vie que j'ai fait mienne cajolant notre
sensibilité notre bien le plus précieux
connectons noël en conscience dans
toutes nos situations même les plus
difficiles
nous réaliserons alors ce que les massaï
appelle la communion sacré entre notre
sensibilité et l'amour qui est la source
de toute chose nous auront vaincu nos
peurs je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]